congressman james e clavern
members of the board of trustees
president kinders
other distinguished guests
platform participants
faculty
staff
students alumni
parents and guardians
graduates
ladies and gentlemen
it is a great day in orangeburg south
carolina
[Applause]
[Music]
and certainly a great day at south
carolina state university
this morning we celebrate the hard work
of our graduates who are seated before
us
in order to maintain the dignity of this
momentous occasion for our students and
their families
we request that all cell phones be
turned off or placed on a solid mode
ladies and gentlemen i am pleased to
introduce
presiding officer for this commencement
exercise our hard-working and visionary
president colonel alexander conyers
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
will you please stand for the posting of
the colors and remain standing for the
national anthem and the black national
anthem
yes yes
oh
pretty good
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
hope that the present has
[Music]
victory is
good morning south carolina state
university
family and friends
[Applause]
on behalf of the board of trustees
faculty staff students and alumni
i'm delighted to welcome you to the fall
2021
commencement convocation
we are honored that you our graduating
class chose south carolina state
university to further your education and
we thank the parents and families for
entrusting your loved ones to our
beloved institution
the reverend a c williams pastor of
trinity united methodist church
orangeburg will give the scripture and
invocation
that will be followed by greetings from
mr rodney jenkins chairman of the board
of trustees
and ms giovanni aries the president of
our student government association
following that we will have a selection
by our south carolina state choral
ensemble
that's right
god of our
very ears
god of our sovereignties
pour out your spirit
upon the president
the united states
of america
his cabinet
the president of south carolina state
university
the board of trustees
faculty
teachers and administrators
158 years after jefferson
declared that all men
are created
equal that they are endowed by
their creator
for certain inhalable
rights
that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
lord we ask that you would
send forth
this class
to be like moses
to address red sea experiences
let them not grow weary
in preparing to create a brighter
horizon for the needs of humanity
lord grant them
favor
wisdom and strength
to persevere
we come to this place
with different background diverse
but all going out to make this world
better
lord make us
to realize that education
must continue
beyond the halls
of south carolina state university
so that goodness must
excel
and days at south carolina state
university
are not in vain
we pray
this day
in your name
for it is in the name
of your son jesus the christ we pray
and all god's children said
amen
good morning with bulldog tenacity
on behalf of the board of trustees i am
delighted to welcome everyone to the
2021 fall commencement convocation of
south carolina state university
the board is honored
to welcome the president of the united
states
joseph r biden
to us to with us today
mr president your presence here
today is historical for our beloved
university so thank you
also
[Applause]
also the boardwell comes home
our loyal son congress congressman james
e claremont
[Applause]
president biden
congressman clyburn
interim president kanye's
staff
ladies and gentlemen
parents
and graduates
the board is truly proud
of the accomplishments of today's
graduates
graduates
we express our sincerest wish
for your success as you navigate the
world of the 21st century with all the
potential and perils most of all
we challenge you to be of service to
mankind and to remember your alma mater
as you go out and do much good in the
world
congratulations to the class of 2021
may god bless everyone and may god
bless south carolina state university
thank you and good morning again
[Applause]
good morning bulldogs
greetings to president biden congressman
clattering elected officials
the board of trustee members
interim president and lady conyers
faculty staff
and most importantly the reason we are
here today the fall class of 2021.
this is an historic occasion
having the opportunity to receive an
encouraging message from the president
of the united states and to witness the
us house majority will walk across the
stage with the phone class of 2021 is
indeed an honor
i am giovanni ayers and i humbly serve
as the student government association
president for this academic school year
it is indeed an honor to congratulate
and come in the fall class of 2021 on
the job well done
whether you're transitioning to your
careers
graduate school the military
wherever the good lord leads you
we hope and pray that you carry and
display the bulldog tenacity and pride
instilled in you during your
matriculation within these groves and
classic halls
in the words of dr matthew l stevenson
iii
great men and women are only born for
the time that they are needed the most
graduates please remember your families
need you your friends need you our
community needs you but most importantly
this world needs you
to our loyal sons and daughters on
behalf of the student body we salute you
for this momentous accomplishment god
bless and hell hell
[Applause]
thank you to the core ensemble
huge thanks to the
282nd army band from fort jackson south
carolina for filling in for us on short
notice as
most of you know our band is in atlanta
so thank you thank you very much for
being a part of this community
[Applause]
thank you to our rotc cadets for posting
other colors
chairman jenkins and our great sga
president miss harris
at this time
it is my honor and privilege
to ask the honorable congressman james e
clyburn to introduce south carolina
state university's fall 2021
commencement speaker
thank you very much mr president
chairman of the board of trustees and
members
of the board
administrators faculty
students
congratulations
now when i
was growing up over in sumter
my dad used to say to me all the time
that the first sign of a good education
is good manners
so
i want
all the members
of this class
to show how well educated you are
stand and say thank you to your parents
your guardians whoever
foot that deal
every month for you to be here stand up
and say thank you
secondly
i want to say to the graduates you today
that
when you start out on your
life's journey
you will not always get it right
i want all of you to remember
what your parents and guardians said to
you
time and time again
if at first
you don't succeed
try
and try again
now
when i got elected to congress
i had already lost three times
and a friend of mine said to me
what are you going to do now
you know what they say
three strikes and you out
i said to my friend
that's a baseball rule
and nobody should live their lives
by baseball rules so i want to say to
you graduates
no matter how many times you attempt
you keep trying
until you get it right
don't
give up
now thirdly i want to say to you
that don't be afraid
to step outside of your comfort zone
you know a lot of us
are limit in what we do because we want
to be comfortable
throughout the whole process
i've been telling the story recently
of thomas anderson
thomas edison is credited with having
invented the light bulb
and that's true
but he couldn't get it to work right
he was not able to get that lightbulb to
work right until he went up to
massachusetts
and sat down
with a young man named lewis
lama
louis vladimir was the son
of former slaves
his parents had escaped
from slavery to boston massachusetts
the lewis latimer had invented something
called a
filament
and someone said to thomas edison you
know
you might be able to get that light bulb
to work right
if you get outside of your comfort zone
go up to massachusetts sit down
with this black guy named louise lavena
and get that filament
that he's invented
and you might be able to get the light
bulb to work
thomas jefferson did that
both he and lucas latimer got outside
their comfort zones
and they admit the world
someone said to each and every one of
you i matriculated here
64 years ago
this past september
also in that class with my late wife
who came to this campus in a pickup
truck
her family didn't own the car
she had a foot locker on the bed
of that pickup truck
and she came to this campus
from a little 22 acre farm in berkeley
county
i don't know what was expected of her
but i know what she did
she came across a little wayward guy
from south to south carolina
and turn it into a united states
congress
[Applause]
not only did she do that
but not long before she passed away
a little over two years ago she said to
me
if we want to succeed
in this upcoming election
we had better
nominate your body
[Applause]
she passed away before
the south carolina primary
but what she said to me that night
stayed on my mind
when i looked among those 20-some odd
candidates
running for the democratic nomination
several of whom were very close friends
of owls
i remembered what she said to me
and i
followed
her directions
just as i had
for the 58 years
that we were married
and so several
weeks ago
i got
i was sitting out having lunch
with the new
president
and he said to me
president congress said
i know the story
if you have not
marched
why don't you consider coming
in marching with the class
of 2021
to celebrate the 60th anniversary
of your having to finish your coursework
i told him i would consider the dinosaur
he said by the way
i would like for you to march
and give the commencement address
i told him i would look into it
but i had something else in mind
and i went to my friend
cedric richmond who was here today
with whom i served in congress i told
cedric
it's eccentric
i'm going to be margin of the class of
2021 to get my diploma
which i never got
now i want you
to help me get
the speaker for the commencement
i didn't tell him that i had already
agreed to do it
i said i think it would be great for me
to get my degree
from the president of the united states
joe biden
he said he told me he would look into it
well
when we reach out to joe biden
he immediately accepted
and
i'm told
that the proper way
to introduce
the president of the united states
is by simply saying ladies and gentlemen
the president of the united states
mr president
dreamers
i uh
i learned a long time ago
that uh
if you wanted to get anything done with
jim you went to his wife
all kidding aside
the story
jim tells is absolutely accurate
i uh
i had i got what we call
my old neighborhood in claim on delaware
i got shellacked
in the first two primaries
and i kept saying
i'm waiting to go to
south carolina
no i mean sincerely because i come from
a state that has the
eighth largest african-american
population and that's the source of all
my support
for real
and uh
i got down here and uh
things are moving pretty slow
and i remember miss emma can say to me
and i heard her say it to jim
we should be for bite
and uh
she's an incredible woman i'll speak
about it a little bit
but you know uh
not only do we win
i think we want every single district
and uh
i just want you to know
it
it matters and jim's saying to you you
know
if you don't succeed at first try again
well a lot of you have already figured
out
that you can do anything you want to do
if you set your mind to it
but one of the things that
most people
don't focus on anymore
is an awful lot of people
like jim like me representing like a lot
of you
who know what expected
to uh
do something significant
i come from a family with a
raise in a three-bedroom split level
home with four kids a dad mom and a
grandpa
we were fine don't get me wrong we
weren't up by our bootstraps but we were
i guess protecting your lower middle
class economically
and i used to stutter really badly
and uh stuttering is the only thing
everybody can still laugh like hell at
but it's devastating to a stutter
if you ever saw the king's speech it's
worth seeing
and i had
trouble
talking until i was
well into
high school
and uh
well i was convinced
that my mother would say
never been never bow
never kneel never give up just get up
just get up
and that's one of the things i like so
much about
hbcus
which i've been part of for a long long
time
the reason i got elected
1972 was because of an hbcu called
delaware state university
they organized for me
[Applause]
so uh
folks uh
you're inheriting an incredible
tradition
graduating from this university
on inauguration day i placed my hand on
the bible
and looked out toward the national mall
what i see
i saw south carolina state baseball cap
oh no not kidding
not kid
talking to two former presidents
clinton and bush
today i look out and i see jim in his
south carolina
state cap and gown
jim i'm honored you asked me to
be here
as you receive your diploma you earned
60 years ago never got a chance to
receive it in person
you know
i know this uh
that
miss emily's here
her spirit and the students are here
today
students on scholarship in her name
students uh
in the honors college in her name
and she is always in our hearts
she was a genuine gift a dear friend
to jill and me and a great american
and she loved this institution
she loved this institution
thank you president conyers the board of
trustees the faculty staff one of our
nation's great universities
though i'm from delaware
i've got to put delaware state up there
the president of delaware state used to
work for me one got his doctor and said
this is not the good job i'm going to be
president university
but all kidding aside of course
president harris
is a proud howard alum
she might have something to say about
delaware state
and to my family and friends the class
of 201 i know the pride
you feel for this day as well
graduates
you already did this because jim did it
but i always do it and gemini as usual
always is ahead of me
you really do hold those folks up in the
bleachers a whole hell of a lot
and i'm sure not a one turned uh husband
and wife and said guess what no tuition
next semester
but uh i i just want to say to the
parents
we know
like my family know the sacrifices you
made to make sure this day arrived
you're the ones that helped you uh get
through this period
and uh and you got a lot a lot to look
forward to
graduates uh i know you've already stood
to thank your parents
and your families
but uh you know the fact is that uh
congratulations you earned it
you earned every bit of it
i know it wasn't easy
remote learning
fearing getting sick from coba 19
feeling the pain
for those who lost loved ones you know
people who've lost one loved ones the
uncertainty
of a devastated economy
a reckoning on race not seen since the
50s and 60s
your time here has come during a
tumultuous and consequential moment
in modern american history
has led you to graduate at a real
inflection point
in history
no graduating class gets to choose the
world into which they graduate
every class
enters the history of the nation up to
the point
that has been written by others
but few classes
every once in a few generations
enter an appointed american history
where it actually has a chance
to change the trajectory of the country
that's not hyperbole
you face that inflection point today
i'm confident you'll meet the moment
you're ready because you're part
of a proud and sacred tradition
an hbcu tradition
more than 180 years
of excellence an institution that is
still a sense of purpose and commitment
to make a difference
in all their students
not just to lift up your cells
but lift up others
an institution grounded in belief that
every american
of every race background and zip code
should have a fair and equal chance
to get as far as their god-given talents
give them
incubators
scholars and educators advocates and
athletes
leaders of industry and entertainment
faith in medicine arts and science
molders of trailblazers visionaries and
public servants
you know it
you know better than anyone
hbcus have helped produce 40
of all the black engineers in america
50
50
all the black lawyers in america
70
of all the black doctors and dentists in
america
[Applause]
and 80
all the black judges in america folks
[Applause]
i see hbcu excellence every single day
in my administration that's not
exaggerated
vice president harris
my cabinet michael
raymond administrative epa
senior white house staff
staff across my entire administration
graduates
i'm here to congratulate you but also
let you know
that your country this is not hyperbole
it's counting on you
they're counting on you
to change to turn the dial
at a moment we have a chance to do it
and that i'm committed to doing
everything i can to make real the
promise of america for all americans for
all of you
that's why my administration has
delivered 5 billion so far to hbcus just
this year
just this year
the more to come
because there's nothing you're unable to
do if you have a product
if you have a laboratories if you have a
lot of these hpcus aren't endowed like
these other universities
for south carolina stated help
to help clear the balance of the more
than 2 500 students assume death
it helps students whether financial
hardships cause that pandemic
and stay in school
financed the residence hall the largest
in south carolina
and that's why
we're working to increase and we will
get it done with jim's helping the house
pell grants
another thousand five hundred dollars so
particularly black students and lower
income families can attend community
college four-year schools in black
university hbcus
that's why i'm proposing a historic
investment to create and expand hbcu
programs
in high demand fields
like cyber security engineering
and health care
these are the big paying jobs getting
out now
but too many
too many hbcus don't have the
laboratories don't have the capacity
they have the intelligence
they have intellectual capacity
but they don't have a research
dilemma in front of them
we're going to create new research and
development labs to prepare students for
jobs in the future and establish hbcu
research hubs all across this nation
i also re-established the president's
board of advisors on hbcus led by a
friend of mine
dr tony allen president of delaware
state university
as i said you still work at my staff
to engage the private sector to advance
hbcus beginning to happen i think your
president will tell you
vice president harris is in constant
contact with leaders of the divine nine
i signed an executive order to advance
hbcu excellence across the
administration in everything from
policies to funding
part of that effort includes recognizing
outstanding hbu's student scholars like
your student government president we
just heard from
javon
congratulations
if there's always more we can do
we're going to lead the way just as jim
has led the way
what makes him so effective
as the highest ranking southern african
american ever
in the house of representatives
is jim
never forgets where he came from
don't you ever forget where you came
from
that's your secret power
you understand
there's no one more effective who knows
how to get things done than someone who
understands the need to get things done
and the people who need it i've been
meaning
who understands what folks are going
through
that's jim and that's many of you and
that was me graduating years ago
with the infrastructure law we just
wrote signed into in the law
and that jim did so much to pass we're
going to create better jobs for millions
of people to rebuild our roads highways
bridges cities small towns rural
communities it means more opportunities
for black businessmen
black contractors black engineers
building black communities back to where
they have to be
and i mean it
if you don't know the community it's
hard to know what it needs
it means every american every child
being able to turn on a faucet and drink
clean water because you're gonna rip up
every lead pipe in america
something that jim is really championing
it means everyone
should be able to access
high-speed internet
urban suburban and rural
graduates you lived it
no student should have to go to a coffee
shop or a fast food restaurant to get
the internet so they can do their
homework
we're going to make sure it never
happens again this is the united states
of america for god's sake
justice reform
we need it from top to bottom
i believe we need judges to understand
the experience of the people where they
come from
that's why i'm proud i appointed black
more black women to the federal bench
circuit court
and and more former public defenders to
the bench in any administration in
american history
the previous record was three black
women in eight years we've confirmed
four in less than eight months and
there's more we can do
there will be lawyers and judges who
will be in charge
who understand understand
real people
and the needs of people
on police reform i share the frustration
and i know the family well george family
justice act and policing act i know the
family well
it's not been passed in the senate but
the fight's not over
despite republican obstructionism in
this bill we've made changes in the
federal law enforcement policies that i
have the ability to do with the stroke
of a pen
the justice department has banned
chokehold restricted no not warrants
required federal agents to wear and
activate body cameras and also ending
the justice department use of private
prisons rescinding previous
administration requirements that u.s
attorneys seek the harshest penalties
the justice department has opened a
pattern of practice investigation into
systemic misconduct to police
departments in phoenix louisville
minneapolis mount vernon new york
but we're just getting started
this administration can continue to
fight for meaningful police reform in
congress
and through additional executive actions
and you will be our next generation of
elected officials
police chiefs civil rights leaders
leading the way
see what just happened in new york city
first black woman
my american rescue plan was passed right
after historic investment in community
policing and violence intervention
programs that are shown to reduce
violence crime violent crime as much as
60
we don't have to spend less money we
have to spend more money employees to
give them the kind of help they
genuinely need
why is the police officer showing up
to the suicide if there's someone trying
to jump off a building
we need more social workers there we
need more psychologists there they need
help
they're basically good people prevent
funds in the first place
first we're expanding summer programs
and job opportunities and other services
to keep young people safe and set them
up for success
we're helping formerly incarcerated
people re-enter their communities
somebody gets out of jail now after
serving their time
what do they get they get a bus ticket
in 25 bucks
and they end up under the same bridge
that got in there in the first place
so i'm going forward and make sure that
everything that's available to anybody
else is available to them
notwithstanding the fact that it already
served their time
we're going to reinstate access to the
pell grants job training apprenticeships
proven pathways to a better way
we need you
we need you to lead a lot of these
efforts
we're also working to stem the flow of
firearms and rogue gun dealers the
current epidemics of gun violence in
this country
no greater victims in the black
communities
we talk about these massive shootings
well guess what there's a massive
shooting every day in urban america
the number of lives that are taken
but you'll lead the way as community
leaders educators faith leaders
non-profit leaders
so my daughter is doing right now she's
a social worker
she's having boys and girls clubs all
across the country
kind of give people alternatives
you got to give them a reason
to think they can make
we're also going to use the federal
government's purchasing power to unlock
billions of dollars in new opportunities
for devastated small businesses
including minority-owned small
businesses to access government
contracts
the goal i've said is 50 percent
increase in the number of minority
contracts going to minority firms by the
year 2025.
because folks
what would we learn
we learned there's no difference between
a black entrepreneur and a white
entrepreneur and
success except the black entrepreneur
usually doesn't have a lawyer
usually doesn't have someone who is
going to be there an account to get it
all set up their idea
is as profound
but the help
is missing
you'll be the entrepreneurs and business
owners accessing that opportunity and
reinvesting in your communities
on housing isn't
it isn't
right if a builder goes out and builds
the exact same home and two different
sides of an interstate one in an all
white network one in all black the same
exact home
the moment the last screw or bolt was
put into that home
and somebody occupies it
a black home is worth 20 less than the
white house
a moment
the moment
you live in a black community you have a
better driving record someone lives in
an all-white community same automobile
your insurance is going to be higher
you didn't write
that home owned by black families and
praise the lower rate at the same time
the homeowner white family has raised
more we're aggressively taking on
housing discrimination
how do folks make it to the middle class
from working class circumstances and
many of you have done that many of your
parents have
you build equity in your home
that's how 90 of the folks make it to
the middle class
they get an opportunity to own a home
and they build equity in a home
allows them to borrow against labor and
send their kids to school to do a whole
range of things
you're going to be the ones that lead
the way not the one that has benefited
you're the ones got to lead the way
because you understand
maybe most important of all we have to
protect that sacred right to vote for
god's sake
i got started in politics because of the
civil rights movement
i noticed some of you were looking i
thought you were wondering how does he
know the black national anthem
well because i sat at the black church
after going to seven o'clock mass i'm a
practicing catholic
and ten o'clock on the east side getting
ready to go out desegregate
restaurants and movie theaters my state
well guess what
i've never seen anything like the
unrelenting assault
on the right to vote
never
i don't think any of you have on this
stage
not a
joke and folks
you know john lewis said
it is the only
without the right to vote there is no
democracy
it's not just about who gets to vote
or make it easier as we used to try to
do to make people eligible to be able to
vote it's about who gets to count the
vote
whether your vote counts at all
folks
i was chairman of the district committee
for a long time
at the end of my stint before i became
vice president
i was able to pass the expense of the
voting rights act for 25 years and guess
what and convince strong thurman of
south carolina to vote for it no no not
a joke
i thought we're finally finally finally
beginning to move
but this new sinister combination of
voter suppression
elections or election subversion
it's un-american
it's undemocratic and sadly it is
unprecedented since reconstruction
vice president harris is leading the
efforts for us but on the anniversary of
bloody sunday
i directed every single federal agency
in the united states government to
process the voting and each agency is
heading
and heeding the call
for example
the department of veterans affairs are
going to make it easy for veterans and
their families to register to go you
know why
because we're going to use va facilities
and they're going to open up for
everybody and nobody's going to stop
anybody
but across the board
in addition the justice department
my justifier is double the voting rights
enforcement staff
challenging the onslaught of state laws
undermining the right to vote
we've supported democrats fighting for
voting rights bills since day one of our
administration making sure that we have
unanimous support among democrats in the
senate which we do
but each and every time it gets to be
brought up
the other team blocks the ability even
to start to discuss it
it used to be called the republican
party
this past not over
we must pass the freedom to vote act to
the john lewis voting rights
we're going to keep up the fight until
we get it done and you're going to keep
up the fight and we need your help badly
and finally
we continue to confront the oldest and
darkest forces in this nation hate and
racism
you know there's a through line
from owensboro massacre that happened 53
years ago that killed three students for
whom this very area
this very arena is named
to darkness that pierced the grace of
mother emanuel
church in charleston which i visited
right afterwards six years ago
to the torches those that everything you
see
in the modern times
people coming out of the fields down in
charleston i mean in charlotte
virginia charlottesville virginia
carrying torches
and nazi banners
screeching
most anti-semitic
and allied black rhetoric in history
hundreds and hundreds of them
and when i asked
the guy who had this job before when
asked what he thought about he said well
there's some very good people there
hell very good people
they're racist they're fascists
and folks
that was four years ago
i never thought i'd see that
in my career
a violent deadly insurrection on capitol
hill 11 months ago on january the 6th
i'm going to say something self-serving
i'm supposed to know an awful lot about
foreign policy
i've known every major world leader in
the last 40 years
i've spoken over 140
heads of state
since i've become president
you know they'll ask me
is america going to be all right
what about democracy in america did you
ever think you'd be asked that question
by another leader
i'm not exaggerating gentlemen
leader of china
xi jinping i met with more than any
other world leader
and putin
both are very straightforward
say democracies can't function
in the 21st century because things are
too complicated they move too fast
in time to get a consensus which
democracies require
that's why autocracies
will rule today
folks
this is a troublesome time of such
significant opportunity
i'm engaged jim and i have engaged in
civil rights work for our entire careers
and more consequential than me
despite all the laws enacted through the
struggles we know
we knew we could make progress
but one of the things i thought jim
probably didn't but i thought jim
i thought we had some of those major
victories we finally crossed the
threshold
but what i didn't realize
is you can defeat hate
but you can't eliminate it
it just slides back under a rock
and when given oxygen
by political leaders
it comes out ugly and mean as it was
before
we can't give it any oxygen
we have to step on it we have to respond
to it
it's not who we are
[Applause]
it's a minority but if the majority
doesn't speak up
it has a profound impact
as we've seen the last few years
we cannot we must not give hate any safe
harbor
we have to shine a bread as light as we
can on it that's the other one
disinfectant call it out
and you're gonna be the light
you're gonna have to be the light
let me close with this
the history of the journey of america
progress of possibilities written by
people
who sat where you're sitting right now
again not hyperbole it's a fact
people like jim and emily kleiber
students who met in a jail cell
after standing up for what was right and
just
who never stopped
in 1961 they were you
now in 2021 you are them
you're part of one of the most gifted
this again is not hyperbole listen to me
and i'm being precise
you're part of the most gifted
tolerant
talented and the single best educated
generation in all of american history
you are
but with that comes a hell of an
obligation
you accept people as they are black
white latino asian native american gay
straight transgender
able to disabled
you see them as people
as fellow americans
who deserve respect and dignity
you're going to see more change
in the next 10 years we've seen the last
50
because of an incredible
incredible change in science and
technology
you're going to see us traveling
commercially
the next 20 years at
12 15 000 miles an hour
subsonic speeds supersonic speed i mean
things are going to change
let's require the educated population
you represent
to understand it
to translate it
to move it
i have every confidence that no matter
your career
you're going to translate change in a
greater opportunity and happiness and
prosperity for you and the world around
you
when i looked out on an inauguration day
i saw that south carolina baseball cap
that i saw
well your hope
and your optimism
that's why i asked a 22 year old amanda
gorman
the youngest inaugural poet in history
to read her poem as a matter of my
professor wife jill
we're still teaching full-time
her and asked her to speak
and here's what she said in her poem
so while once we asked
how could we possibly prevail over
catastrophe
now we assert
how could contestants possibly prevail
over us
will not march back to what was but move
on to what shall be
a country that is
busy excuse me as bruised but whole
benevolent but bold
and fierce and free
that's who we are
that's who you are the class of 2021.
i'm not joking that's us that's america
we face that inflection point that's
going to change the course history and
i'm counting on you
to meet the moment
it's an enormous opportunity
an enormous opportunity
because i truly believe
someone standing at a podium like this
at this university
40 years from now
you're going to be talking about
did we meet the moment
this moment
just like there's other moments in our
history did we meet the moment
in world war one did we meet the moment
when we go down the list
it's going to determine what happens the
next five to ten years
is going to determine what's going to
look like 50 years from now
i'm counting on you
i really am i'm not kicking off the
responsibility but i'm counting on you
congratulations to all of you
merry christmas
and happy holidays
i say to the military god bless you all
may god protect our truths
[Applause]
president conyers
ladies and gentlemen it is my privilege
to present the candidate for the
honorary degree
many thanks to you president biden for
sharing this very special occasion with
south carolina state university
thank you for your remarks of
encouragement and challenge to our
graduates
and i can assure you that the graduates
before you this morning
will
meet the moment
and for your leadership and dedication
to our nation
chairman jenkins please come forward
it is a great honor for the university
to confer honorary doctors upon
individuals who have made significant
contributions in various arenas
this morning upon the recommendation of
the honorary degrees committee the board
of trustees
has approved the 46th president of these
united states
joseph r biden jr to receive this
prestigious honor
by virtue
of authority vested in me by the state
of south carolina i hereby confer upon
you the degree for which you have been
recommended the honorary doctor of
humane letters
with all the rights and privileges
appertaining
thereof
congressman clyburn please escort
president biden to the center of the
stage
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
congratulations president
bulldog biden
[Applause]
the confirm of the degrees
will all candidates for doctor of
education education specialist master of
business administration
masterbots
master of education the master of
science degrees please stand and remain
standing
will the candidates for the
bachelor
bachelorette
science bachelor of social work degrees
also stand
president congress these candidates have
satisfactorily completed all the
requirements for graduation
they have been approved by the faculty
and the board of trustees
it is now my pleasure to present them to
you for the confirm of their degrees
by